- All right, everybody,
let's check out social media
for one last great story before we go.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
(audience clapping)
For parents of toddlers,
good luck first of all,
but you're lucky if your
kid finishes his peas.
Not the case for a family
in Buffalo, though.
This is 2-year-old, Levi,
who regularly dines on everything
from watermelon gazpacho
to squid pasta,
which for a billion dollars I
couldn't get my kids to eat.
His chef dad curates the menu
and posts the results on Instagram.
Let's get these foodies in here.
Say hi to Levi and his dad,
Jack, who watch on WKBW
in Buffalo, New York.
Hi y'all.
- Hi guys.
- Oh my gosh, Levi, you're so cute.
So, you're kind of, Jack,
you're kind of his private chef, right?
- Yes, I am, yeah.
Cooking has been my passion
for the last 10 years.
I've worked in fine dining, catering,
and cook for professional athletes,
and once Levi was born,
I knew I wanted to share
my love of food with him.
So, it started as early
as making all his baby food from scratch,
and now it's progressed
to cooking him scallops,
chicken adobo, braised oxtail,
and many other dishes that
even some adults haven't tried.
His amazing reactions and his curiosity
when trying all these foods
led me to document our
culinary journey together.
And that's how Cooking for Levi started.
We wanna inspire families
to cultivate a healthy
relationship with food,
and it's been a surreal
experience with the amount of love
and feedback we've gotten from everyone.
And it's allowed me to
be a stay-at-home dad
and Levi's private chef.
(audience laughing)
- You're getting upstaged, yeah.
He's like.
So wait, Levi, so you have something
you're about to try, right now, food wise?
- Yeah, so he actually
helped prepare this with me.
- Okay.
- He helped me cut up all these fruits.
This is a, we call it the ocean parfait.
- Wait, can you lift it?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, that's delicious looking.
- So yeah, it's like a
little fun little idea
to make with your kids.
- Well, if I made it look like that
my kids would eat it.
I was like, yeah.
- So this is a Greek
yogurt that's colored,
naturally colored with blue spirulina,
and then we grounded up some
graham crackers for the sand
and these are just a
bunch of different fruits.
Why don't you give it a try, Levi?
- Oh my, forget Levi.
I live at, I'm just kidding.
I'm like, what?
That looks delicious.
- Yeah, it's fun to be creative.
- Maybe if I plated it like a beach
at Disney World, they'd eat it.
Oh my God, I love it.
Thank you so much for
inspiring us families.
This is incredible.
Aw, he's even sharing.
Well, thank you so much Jack.
Bye, Levi, thank you for joining us.
I'm liking your post right now.
(bell dings)
And that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2 and the new G2 Edge,
the go-to pens of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor inspiring
families just like yours,
so they're gonna be writing y'all a check
for $1,000 for a really great menu.
- Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- Absolutely.
Y'all have a good one
and thank you all our guests this hour.
Rob Gronkowski, Kali Reis,
Sydney McLaughlin-Levrone,
Nicole, Madison, Logan, and Winifred.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, change it.